when you're like 15 16 like you don't
realize that you're not even born yet
they literally are sitting there
thinking they they're getting close to
having to have their [__] figured out
kids I got a big one for you you know
how your parents and teachers are
telling you like you got to get [__]
focused you got to figure out your [__]
you're not going to believe this it's
really [__] funny none of them have
their [__] figured
out none none attention is the number
one asset uh Gary going to go through a
couple questions here with you uh uh
first of all what about last week in the
Jets oh I saw a jet shirt I see you I
saw you and I also saw Tiara wack
[__] there we go let's [__] go um
the Jets it's all about this weekend
we're at a Crossroads we're two and
three you all know our [__] got [__]
up four [__] plays into the season
but we got the Eagles who are
ridiculously tough I actually like the
eagles a lot cuz we both hate the
[__]
Giants but I'm hoping I'm hoping for a
miracle cuz if we can win this week it
starts getting excited if not it gets a
little tricky you start looking towards
the draft tell me this man we're we're
obviously at a the Spire event but uh
you just announced uh another one of
your events vcon yes coming up in La yes
what's the passion of throwing these big
events for Von and stuff you know the
nft thing for a lot of you that either
were paying very close attention or
weren't paying attention at all when the
nft thing hit obviously I believe in it
so much and I believe in the blockchain
heavy in the height of the height August
2000 I started making a ton of content
saying 99 % of these things are going to
zero because I was starting to see
everyone just went to the greed side not
the building and the patience and the IP
side but for me V friends the characters
you saw up there it's my Pokemon meet
Sesame Street you know I have a lot of
passion for what I just talked about I
think you're get you know a lot of you
have been along this journey you're
starting to get more insight to what
makes me tick I I know that me as a
person has been able to amass an
audience but I know I'm not everyone's
cup of tea watch this how many people
here the first time they saw me were
like [__] that dude he's a douche Make
Some Noise
yes dude what the
[__] so you know luckily luckily for the
people that raised their hand you get
lucky sometimes and people will give you
you know you get a couple more bats they
hear the right thing and and you could
make that jump but there's a lot of
people that will never even give me a
second chance or someone that looks like
me I get it and I'm not for everyone we
all consume differently and there's
different voices different backgrounds I
get it with be friends my Sesame Street
meets Pokemon if I can't teach you
patience well then I'm going to make
patient Panda so [__] popular that
they're going to get to your kids and
then and so it's a very big mission of
mine I you know at first I thought I was
building Disney but then as I learned
more about what Jim Henson did with
Sesame Street and Fraggle Rock there was
a lot of meaning behind those characters
and I'm very inspired by that and so
anyway when I did the nft thing I kind
of anticip ipated the chance that it
would take some time I didn't anticipate
the prices would get so crazy greed
really took over I didn't anticipate the
government sending everybody free money
you know there's a lot of [__] that went
into it but I knew that the blockchain
allowed me to do unique things so the
fact that you would get this collectible
right this feed friends collectible I
wanted to make sure there was real life
value so I said for a long time I've
been wanting to do a South by Southwest
meets rolling loud like what's what
would the coolest business conference
look like
and so when I did be friends I'm like
this is my chance I'm going to sell
these I'm going to make the initial
selling of them the collectible have
three years to this conference we did in
Minnesota the first year we to Vikings
play we did it last year we're to Colts
play in Indianapolis this year I wanted
to try a different format so we're doing
it in LA live in August and I'm really
proud of it and I've learned a lot about
events it's 10,000 people it's it's a
big event you know Snoop and farel and
Drew Barrymore and just like a lot of
pop culture you know Andrew Schultz did
stand up buster Rhymes performed like I
really I'm really going for it i' be
it's I want it's almost like I didn't I
didn't have the kind of money as a kid
to go to summer camp you know but for me
having this event to look forward to
every summer where I can really talk
about pop culture and business and
marketing and Innovation and so this is
the last year that only the nft holders
can go and then I've got a decision to
make where I go with it afterwards but
I'm really excited about it very cool
man let me obviously in a room full of
entrepreneurs and business owners and uh
uh we're all growing and scaling if you
can uh paint a little bit of vision uh
that we can see down on scaling uh I I
think you just surpassed 2500 staff
employees now 2,000 2,000 at your
company uh for us that are in the room
growing and scaling scale that up give
us a vision what is that like when I
went into my dad's store at a school we
had eight employees doing three million
bucks and five years later we had almost
200 people doing $50 million a year when
I started Vayner media because my dad
really never paid me much money I I
don't think people it's funny for me
when people try to Ras me they're like
he inherited I'm like [__] I
inherited nothing dick I built a huge
business for my father and left and
didn't have anything which is why I had
to start Vayner media in a conference
room of another company I promise you if
I inherited it we would had [__]
chairs uh you know so so I started vayer
media very humbly and in 14 years not
knowing anything about that world we
built a $350 million business with 2,000
employees I I feel confident that I can
speak about scaling the number one
reason brother that most people here
will not scale to the level that they
want to is because they don't love their
employees
enough the real answer to the quiz is
realizing you work for people not
they're beholden to you because you
write their check the way that employers
treat employees when they have big
aspirations and it's their company I'm
not talking middle management and a
corporation you're both in [__] jail
I'm talking it's your [__] and you want
it to be as big as possible the two
biggest mistakes people make is they
don't invest in people like really like
really for example I have 2,000
employees I that's just Vayner X I have
vriends I have [__] vayer Sports I'm
always still helping my dad because
that's our relationship with Wine
Library win text I'm doing got the Gary
ve brand I've got a I got a pickle ball
team I got a ton of [__] going on and
yet if you looked at my calendar I'll
show you right now real talk watch this
tomorrow I promise you like [__] no
forget that don't look at how many it's
what it's what in these 15minute
meetings it's with employee Paige Carlin
one-on-one Destiny John oneon-one right
Charles oneon-one yeah one-onone one-on
one 15 minutes 15 minutes 15 minutes you
just don't [__] care about them
enough wow and if you don't care about
them first how the [__] do you expect
them to care about your
[__] that's number one number two the
biggest reason most of you will not get
to where you want to get to promise you
the biggest reason is because you have a
business to buy dumb [__] yeah yeah yeah
what ends up happening is you got to go
in a little bit you're doing 2 million a
million you got 200,000 in profit and
you take all that [__] and buy some
shoes instead of leaving it hiring more
people and doing 4 million the next year
you're you you're using your business
for your
lifestyle instead of you building your
business so so for me I don't think I
had a salary over $100,000 until almost
40 because my dad definitely didn't pay
me [__] and then when we started Vayner
media I was already kind of in that
mindset and so I was just reinvesting
Vayner media went from zero to 1.8 1.8
to 3 then I went full-time 3 to 14 14 to
27 27 to 48 48 to 72 but the way I was
able to do that was along the way I
wasn't trying to buy another house or a
[__] boat I was trying to build a
business and the biggest reason people
will not scale here is they don't care
about their people at all sometimes or
enough and they use their business to
fund their lifestyle and they don't
build a business they build a machine of
cash to like live which is by the way do
you you can do whatever the [__] you
want this is
America but if you're asking me why I
see people stay at 2 three 4 five it has
to do with all the [__] in their closet
that they don't wear yeah yeah I want to
do this one
thing I found out today uh when he came
here Gary uh uh a school teacher um that
teaches entrepreneurship and finance to
a group of kids uh uh uh paid uh for
probably around 50 high schoolers uh
that he teaches uh to come to this event
it's amazing he got the bus for them
paid for the bus paid for the food uh
did the whole thing we found out it uh
here and we we put a special room in
together for them and did some stuff
with them uh but where's that group of
of high schoolers at where you there
they are right over there there they
are
if uh obviously work with a lot of young
people no kids don't take the eighth
place trophy it's going to [__] you up
so when they hand it to you [__]
throw it back in their [__] face you
got
it what uh you obviously work with a lot
of uh of people but young people in high
school in my [__] favorite what would
you what advice would you give let me
tell you one other thing when we [__] on
j z you need to hear me loud and clear
as you're going to go home tomorrow and
complain again that no nobody wants to
take this job that you're offering $18
an hour for J Z is not Lazy J Z has
options we have to they know that they
can just [__] make Tik toks and get
brand Deals they know that they can flip
[__] on eBay they know they can do a
Shopify store I promise you if we all
had the internet we wouldn't have worked
at Kmart
either that's good [__] if I had
the internet I wouldn't have graduated
Middle School let alone [__] high
school I would have been by 11 be like
peace Mr Dennis [__]
you [__] all right I would have the Jets
20 years ago I had the internet when I
was a kid [__] [__] I wish I had that
[__]
[__] what what what piece of advice if
you gave him one piece of advice now in
high school what what would you tell the
the the high schoolers over there
there's so much which is why I make so
much so much content on Tik Tok and we
all remember when you're like 15 16 like
you don't realize that you're not even
born yet like they literally are sitting
there thinking they they're getting
close to having to have their [__]
figured out kids I got a big one for you
you know how your parents and teachers
are telling you like you got to get
[__] focused you got to figure out
your [__] you're not going to believe
this it's really [__] funny none of
them have their [__] figured
[Laughter]
out none
[Applause]
none so what I what I would tell them is
and I would tell this to a lot of people
in this room especially looking at the
20 30 and 40y old 50 60 year old faces
we have such a bad relationship with
time it's it's a big passion of mine I
know that people that follow me here
know how much I pound this with modern
medicine do you know that they're going
to live to 130 yeah like real [__] like
I don't know if anyone's paying
attention to what's going on it's crazy
modern medicine is moving fast we are
figuring out a ton of [__] like people
like literally if you're 124 14 15 16
buck 10 Buck 15 Buck 20 Buck 30 for real
and before you're like nah just do your
homework look at what's been happening
85 are you kidding me if somebody lived
to 60 in the 1970s they were like you
[__] made
it so what I would tell them is and I
would tell a lot of you and this is goes
back to like this is going to be a fun
one because I'll tell them and then I'm
going to you for them they need to be
high risk yeah they need to follow their
actual dream actually they need to
mitigate regret you know what is really
hurting for a lot of people in here the
[__] they didn't do at 20 and 30 that
they wanted
to right cuz they thought they were
supposed to or their mommy made them do
it or Society told us I get it [__] when
I when I was a kid like entrepreneurship
wasn't even a thing at 14 15 16 everyone
told me besides my mom that I was going
to be a loser cuz I got D's and Fs kids
I got D's and
Fs like you know like we didn't have the
you know who Gary B is online besides
trying to make my mom proud he's the
person I wish existed for me when I was
16 yeah yeah you understand yeah yeah
which is why I talk about the [__]
of n like if I like I needed someone to
look up to there's too many people that
say win at all cost kill everybody [__]
you I don't believe in that [__] I
believe there's two ways to build the
biggest building in town one just have
the [__] talent to do it or two like
most people tear down everybody else's
building Y and so I think about that and
I want to be that role model I want to
be that person for 15y old me if they
happen to sit there but if you're a
musician if you want to be a
stay-at-home Dad if you want to coach
little league I don't know what you're
about but whatever it is at this age for
the next 20 years nothing but that and
then if you didn't have the talent if it
didn't didn't bounce your way if you
weren't good enough if it just didn't
click then at the ripe age of
33 you can go get a regular job yeah and
for This Crew I wish they knew what 50
is in today's world yeah when people are
like it's over what's over you're going
to be up 30 40 more like what you're
just going to dwell for 30
years I wish people knew that the number
one thing they should do right now if
they're not enjoying it though I don't
know if you heard everyone's happy in
here yeah they
happy but if you one of those two people
that didn't
clap if you're not pumped with what you
do do you understand how much time we
spend on
working when add sleeping and then
figure out how much work is your life
it's the majority of your life if you
don't like it you're making a mistake
and I understand [__] you Gary that's
dream [__] I got a mortgage I got I get
it but I don't understand why people
don't fight for their happiness yeah do
like and let me and let me go in let me
go into detail let me go into
detail in my way of seeing the
world if you can't quit your thing to go
try to do another thing you start
looking at everything that costs you
money if you're actually miserable real
talk like if you don't wake up on Monday
and you're like yeah
right like people that live for Friday
evening that's not
life if you're one of those people the
first thing you look at is do you own a
home if you own a home and you're not
happy like really not happy but you
can't afford to jump I think it's a
debate to say let me sell this home let
me take out the equity give me a year
I'll have the humility right I'll go
back to an apartment I'll go to a
smaller home I'll rent a smaller home
but we don't do it because we're worried
about
judgment most of you will not do the
thing you should do to get to happiness
because you don't want to be
embarrassed and that [__] me up it's
like sports most of you are living your
life can you imagine if every
athlete reacted to every time they were
booed when you're an athlete you don't
even hear the [__] crowd when people
try to tell me or judge me on what I'm
doing I'm like [__] you're in
the crowd eating popcorn I'm [__]
fling so if you need to [__] sell
your home because you bought a home that
was too big for your
skis and
you the Realtors are [__]
aren't
they and you have a home that has I
don't know four rooms that you never
[__]
use and it's [__] you up cuz that
mortgage is [__] you up and your
lease as a [__]
Tesla and you go on three vacations for
the [__] photos on the gram to show
people you're winning on the outside but
and you're actually losing on the
inside swallow some [__] humility and
fight for your
[Applause]
happiness
last uh Gary uh last question here for
the day uh Alex if you got to come out
uh so Gary me and you're talking about
stage and what a lot of these guys don't
know is a Spire would actually never
exist uh without uh the very first
interview I ever did with money is kind
of launched this whole freaking thing uh
about four years ago in your office and
we were talking about backstage so I'm
gonna you're the first person we ever
did the interview with I don't know if
you remember your answer but I remember
it uh I didn't tell you what it was uh
but if I asked it to you again uh money
is blank what would the answer be and
then why would it be that money is an
exposer an
exposer my friends money
exposes if you're a piece of [__] when
you're
poor you're really a piece of [__] when
rich I love when people like Gary money
changed him I'm like no it didn't I
promise you money is an exposer money
exposes people y real talk yeah it
[__] exposes people it just
accelerates Your Truth yeah it it just
does you're you're good people you get
paper you're real good people promise
watch it pay attention it's never ever
been any other way money money is an
exposure
perspective is what we think money does
when you decide to not look here and you
look here and you see completely
different [__] you can possibly act
different yeah that is what people think
money does for them putting in the work
having the humility it took me time to
get to understanding cander was a flaw I
used to blame them I was doing this
right I'm really good at this for almost
everything but when I wasn't strong
enough to fire you CU I liked you
because I mean once up back to what I
said earlier you come into my company
we're [__] family like I think in
sports terms you're like on my team now
right like we're going to kill everybody
and I start getting feelings I do like I
love my [__] teams and so when I
would when someone
sucked instead of having the ability to
say hey you're not good at this and
build like have the ability to build
them up I would just because I didn't
want it and it would get worse and worse
and worse and then after three years of
them sucking and I would sloppily fire
them out of I mean it was bad in my 20s
it was out of control at 28 I could like
walk by somebody at the liquor store and
be like Johnny you're the [__] best
see you on Monday like on a Saturday
night and then Monday be like yo can you
come to my office real quick yo by the
way you're fired
and he Johnny's like [__] you
said I was the best on Saturday and I
was like [__] I'm sorry I'm like here's
more money just get the [__] out of the
company you know like like it was sloppy
it was sloppy yeah and you know what I
did I blamed them I'm like Johnny [__]
you Johnny how didn't you you [__]
sucked you knew you sucked what the [__]
you know and I wasn't there and I think
we do that on a lot of things and so I
think we need to be we need to be way
more accountable like the second you
realize the world is how you see it even
in times like this if you want to look
outside right now you can find unlimited
positivity and a second you realize that
anything that is bothering you is on you
it's on you every single person here is
more than capable of fixing it maybe not
this
minute but if you believe otherwise
you've already
lost if you believe you can't fix it
I'll never get my mom that's if you
believe that then it won't
happen and more importantly back to
before this this is at Von I set a funny
line with passion I said [__] your
grandparents I'm really excited about
this yeah let's talk that out for a
second
yeah so many people [__] on their
parents because that's what we do as
humans we blame our parents yeah yeah
like my M like you don't get it Gary I
can't you especially the way I talk
about my parents and my mom you can
imagine right going through the airports
on DM Gary you don't get it I can never
cuz unlike you my mom was poison and I'm
like but then when you really go deep as
I have over the last 20 years on this
people are all mad at their parents but
they love Grandma cuz when they went
over there she gave them
pie Meanwhile your grandma is the one
that made your mom the way she is yeah
and so we give Granny a pass yeah yeah
but we [__] on Dad like a [__]
yeah yeah and then there's a funny game
once you get to that place then you
realize wait a minute great grandma was
a real
[__] and so my question is you can sit
here and continue to blame the President
right your mom or you can decide I'm a
grown ass man I'm a grown ass girl and
instead of doing all these proxies to
make makeup on my problem let me go do
work
yeah let me do
work cuz it's super easy to blame it's
easy you just do it but people are not
putting in the work and what again so to
me money it's a people swear that that's
just shit's that's going to fix it if
you got [__] up [__] that [__] is not
fixing it it's going to make you spend
that [__] on more [__] up [__] and
you're going down down [__] town I
love it I love it Charlie Brown
[__] know all right that's it
Gary you guys give Gary a round of
applause man Gary V thank you San
Diego